Nice, ni-ni-ni-ni-nice!
Ja, auf geht's!
Eleko, der eigentliche für den Sub.
20 Monate, das ist ja richtig.
Wenn ich den Sound finde, das ist ja richtig.
Immer noch.
Ich werde es mir wahrscheinlich nie merken können.
Trotz 20 Monate Dauersubscription.
Ja, heute ist es soweit, Leute.
Heute gucken wir uns die neue Version von.
Nein, warum ist das so klein?
Was auch immer.
Heute gucken wir uns die neue Shit Air Version an.
Ich habe übrigens auch gerade meine neuesten .files gepusht.
Falls sich das irgendjemand zu Gemüte führen möchte.
Ich werde ja öfters mal gefragt.
Habe ich gerade gepusht vor 16 Minuten.
Hat sich nicht so viel geändert.
So ein paar Sachen sind hinzugekommen.
Ein paar sind weggeflogen.
Google Cloud Tools sind dazugekommen.
Ansonsten hat sich nicht so viel geändert.
Ja, das müssen wir mal gucken.
Womit verwaltest du die mit damit?
Wobei das ist französisch.
Ich glaube, das heißt eher oder sowas.
Wobei ich französische Aussprache muss nicht sein.
Ich würde sagen, ich mache mal ein Update.
Und dann, weil es ist Arsch, es gibt immer Updates.
Ach du Scheiße.
Wie auch immer.
Ich finde Chatsmoy viel besser.
Oder was sagt ihr Leute?
Chatsmoy oder Chatsmoy?
So, wir machen alles wieder eine Runde geupdatet.
Jawoll, wunderbar.
Exzellent, exzellent.
Und jetzt hauen wir nochmal ein Reboot hinterher,
weil das kann nie schaden.
Übrigens, der Stream gestern,
ich zeige euch gleich mal was richtig Cooles,
was ich gebroggert habe heute tagsüber.
Man muss ja irgendwas Produktives im Homeoffice machen.
Tatsächlich was Cooles.
Der Stream gestern hat mich dazu inspiriert.
Wie hältst du die Tabs auseinander?
Gar nicht.
Gar nicht, ich gucke manchmal hier oben drüber dann so.
Aber ansonsten eher gar nicht halte ich die auseinander.
Ist iPhone in Combo der Uhr gut?
Ach, woher soll ich?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Uhr.
Ich habe keine Apple, Apple.
Kein Apple Clock.
Nutzt du Arch in einer Windows VM?
Nee.
Ach so, ja.
So meinst du das.
Ich benutze Arch in einer VM unter Windows.
So rum, ja das ist richtig.
Guck da, guck hier, da, VM.
Weil bei Workstation nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich das so gemacht habe.
Mal kurz hier, Firefox auf, Terminal auf,
so dass das wieder halbwegs erträglich aussieht.
Ich habe das so gemacht, man kann jetzt ja seit Windows 10 glaube ich,
ich glaube vorher gab es das noch nicht.
Paper, Wallpaper, ey.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe da nichts mal von gehört.
Es gibt jetzt seit Windows 10 gibt es ja hier mehrere Desktops.
Und ich habe es einfach so gemacht,
ich habe da auf dem ersten Desktop meinen ganz normalen Windows Shit
und auf dem zweiten Desktop einfach im Fullscreen meine VM mit Arch.
Selbstverständlich, by the way, NeoFetch, Arch, by the way, was sonst?
Ich glaube da müssen wir gar nicht diskutieren.
Das ist selbstverständlich, use ich Arch, da sind wir uns ja einig.
Leute, das ist ja logisch.
Ich hoffe ihr auch, ich hoffe ihr auch.
Wenn nicht, wenn nicht, dann stimmt mit euch ja irgendwas.
Nein, nein, ich bin kein Mal, ich bin nicht mal auf Manjaro unterwegs.
Guck mal, Arch Linux, original, Yepcock, bestel.
So muss das sein.
Es muss Arch sein und ich muss euch das mindestens 50 Mal heute Abend erzählen noch,
dass ich Arch, by the way, verwende, nur dann ist das echt.
Ja, das ist raw Arch selbst gemoddet, soweit wie es geht.
Selbstverständlich, klar was sonst?
Korrekt, so sieht es aus.
Cringe, wer nicht Suse nutzt?
Ja, ich würde eher sagen Cringe, wer Suse nutzt.
Oder Cringe, wie heißt das?
Tumbleweed oder so heißt doch dieses komische Suse unstable jetzt.
Wo ich mich immer frage, wer um alles in der Welt soll wirklich Suse verwenden?
Gibt es einen Grund?
Na ja, eigentlich nicht so wirklich.
Außer dass man viel cooler ist, wenn man offizielles Arch Linux verwendet.
Weil man darf ja nicht mehr sagen, dass man Arch, by the way, verwendet,
wenn man Manjaro benutzt und nachdem das Wichtigste ist,
beim Arch Linux verwenden eigentlich permanent zu sagen,
dass man Arch Linux verwendet, brauche ich schon ein Original,
dass ich es auch sagen darf.
Doch, Suse ist richtig mies, Alter.
Ich kriege Anfälle, immer wenn ich Suse benutzen muss.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich habe jetzt schon zwei Sachen und ihr wisst, ich kann mir das mit fast 40.
Na gut, na ja, nur nicht ganz.
Mit fast 39 kann ich mir das nicht mehr alles merken.
Ich wollte euch...
Was wollte ich euch zeigen? Keine Ahnung.
Ach so, ja, das ist der Stream gestern.
Wer gestern nicht dabei war, gestern war ein bisschen spontan,
konfus, aber das gestern hat mich dazu inspiriert, dass...
Manchmal macht es mich hier durcheinander.
Gestern hat es mich, ja genau, gucken wir uns mal die eigene Werbung an,
gestern hat es mich inspiriert und zwar, wir haben gestern diesen Stream gemacht,
neues .NET 8 Feature nun Konkurrenz für Go.
Wir haben relativ wenig zu dem Streamtitel gestern gemacht,
sondern wir haben uns damit auseinandergesetzt,
wie man VMs über die CAP Verledigungs startet.
Das hat mich dazu inspiriert und das Projekt können wir heute eigentlich
auch so als Testgrundlage nehmen, weil wir einfach ein bisschen
Source Code brauchen, um Shit EA zu testen.
Und das hat mich inspiriert und zwar, ich habe heute im Homeoffice
Brogger Stels gemacht.
Heckermann Stels und ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Passt mal auf.
VMChamp.
Wie soll das Ding auch sonst bitteschön heißen?
Run 0v.
Und jetzt guckt mal.
Richtig, richtig ein nicees Konsol UI haben wir am Start.
Er stellt mir eine VM.
Ich gucke nicht mit dem Wirt Manager, das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck.
Da sage ich, ich zeige es euch jetzt nur, dass er tatsächlich eine VM erstellt.
Im Hintergrund die VM startet.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Passt mal auf.
Wenn er fertig die VM starten ist, dann holt er sich eine IP.
Und jetzt werdet ihr feststellen, guckt mal da.
Der hat sich direkt auf meine neue VM per SSH connectet.
Seht ihr das?
So.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen VMChamp.
VM 0v heißt die VM und jetzt die VM wieder weg.
Das ist mega nice für schnelle VMs zu erstellen.
Guckt mal.
Man hat sogar Help.
Man hat sogar Hilfe Ausgabe.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Das Ding hat auch Shell Completion.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt das hier so in meine Shell Config schreiben.
Und dann hat er automatisch Shell Completion.
Es wird noch viel advanceder.
Es wird noch viel besser.
Das gibt es noch nicht auf Shithub, aber das können wir auf Shithub posten.
Das wird noch viel advanceder.
VMChamp.
Okay.
Run.
Name für VM.
Tolle VM.
Und jetzt.
Passt mal auf.
Shell Completion.
OS kann man auswählen, was man für den Image haben will.
Und jetzt haltet euch fest sogar Image Name Completion.
Ich will einen Debian 10 haben.
So.
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Der lädt das Image runter.
Mit coolem Konsolen-UI.
Zeigt auch von wo und wo.
Dann wartet er auf das Netzwerk.
30 Sekunden.
Und wenn das Netzwerk da ist, dann connectet er sich per SSH.
Und dann.
Wird gleich noch advanceder.
Richtig Hackermanship.
Das dauert ein bisschen, bis die VM gestartet ist.
Und wisst ihr, wie ich das gemacht habe?
Dass ich mich auf die VM connecten kann danach.
Ich hab ein eigenes Cloud Image.
Cloud Init ISO erstellt.
Was ich in die VM hänge.
Was dann die VM konfiguriert beim booten.
So, jetzt bin ich auf meiner VM drauf.
Update.
Wie auch immer.
Upgrade.
Ihr seht, die VM funktioniert ganz normal.
Jetzt kann ich wieder raus aus der VM.
Und jetzt kann ich zum Beispiel sagen.
VMChamp.
List.
Wenn ich nicht weiß, was ich für VMs habe.
Hab ich sogar eine Tabelle.
Was ich für VMs aktuell besitze.
Und es wird noch besser.
Ich kann sogar, wenn ich mich darauf connecten will.
Noch sagen.
VMChamp.
SSH.
Und dann hab ich sogar Autocomplete für SSH.
Autocomplete für SSH.
Und bin schon wieder auf der VM drauf.
Das ist nicht Placingly Fast Written in Rust.
Das ist
Steinarter. Danke schön für den Zap.
.NET.
Ich kann das Repo gleich auch mal klonen.
Ja.
Warum?
Autsch, ist doch nice.
Und guck mal.
Ich hab das mit dem neuen
Compiler Feature
von .NET 8 ausprobiert.
Das gesamte Binary ist
bloß 12 MB groß.
Und das startet
auch saumäßig schnell. Guckt mal.
Machen wir mal Help.
Time.
Das braucht einfach nur 6
Millisekunden.
Das ist also wirklich
sehr, sehr zackig.
Irgendwas stimmt mit
meinem Default.
Default Sachen wohl nicht so ganz.
VM, tolle VM. Was? Hä?
Warum kein Arch
bei den Images? Kann man einfach hinzufügen.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
So. Und jetzt,
wenn man fertig, also ihr seht ja,
das war mehr oder weniger die ganze Funktion schon.
So. Und wenn ihr fertig seid,
machen wir noch mal einen anderen. Machen wir
einen Test nochmal. Eine Sache zeige ich euch noch schnell.
Vor,
in. Wir machen jetzt einfach mal 10
VMs.
Macht keinen Sinn, aber es
funktioniert. Seht ihr auch einfach, dass es schnell
funktioniert. VMChamp.
Run.
Und der Name von der VM ist jetzt
einfach VM$I.
Dann. So. Wenn man sonst nichts
angibt, dann macht er ein Standard
Image. Standard Image ist Debian 11.
Ach so, Moment. Siehst du, ich bin
ich bin pepega. Ich bin blöd. Ich habe es
wieder nicht. Ich habe es wieder nicht gecheckt. Ich muss noch
eine Option angeben. Und zwar
kann ich noch Option angeben
minus minus
Background.
In irgendwelchen Gründen geht
Shell Completion in der Schleife
nicht. Okay. Minus minus Background
kann ich angeben. Und dann
erstellt er das alles.
Ja. Dann erstellt
er das alles asynchron
im Hintergrund. Also wenn man hier den
Wirtmanager aufmacht, dann
ihr seht es ja auch schon. Meine VM ist etwas
ausgelastet mit nested Virtualisierung
gerade. So. Und schon habe
ich 10 VMs. Nicht, dass ich die
brauchen würde, aber ich zeige einfach nur, dass
es funktioniert.
Meine VM ist halt mit nested
Virtualisierung gerade ein bisschen ausgelastet. So.
Und wenn ich jetzt fertig bin
mit ausprobieren, dann kann ich
einfach sagen VMChamp
clean. Und dann sagt er mir
Going to delete
all VMs and images, sogar 12
VMs. Wollen Sie das wirklich
machen? Yes.
Und alles
wieder weg. Inclusive
images. Inclusive images.
Wenn ich jetzt wieder eine VM
starte,
wenn ich jetzt wieder eine VM starte, muss er
das Image neu runterladen. Guckt.
Also er hat wirklich alles aufgeräumt.
VMs, VM Disks,
images, alles was man gemacht hat. Das heißt
es ist super
einfach immer auf die schnelle
sich Test VMs zu erstellen.
Wo ist das
Repo noch bei mir lokal nur? Aber ich kann es
gleich pushen. Wartet mal.
Ich check
das Repo mal kurz lokal aus.
Wäre nice, wenn die VMs
irgendwie getaggt werden, dass man weiß, dass sie mit
VMChamp erstellt sind, sonst sind
die eigenen erstellten auch danach. Nein
sind sie nicht. Die sind nicht weg.
Der merkt sich, welche VMs von ihm
erstellt wurden. Und
guck mal, der kann das doch auch
listen.
Der merkt sich, wo welche
VMs er erstellt hat. Guckt,
das merkt er sich hier. Es gibt hier einfach jetzt
eine Datei VMChamp
im Heimatverzeichnis und da ist das
alles drin. Ach so, das
Ganze ist sogar Workspace ready. Wenn ich Bock
habe, kann ich Workspaces einbauen,
dass man mehrere Sachen parallel
betreiben kann.
Guck hier auf VMs, da ist der ganze Shit drinne.
Und in
Cache sind die
Images.
Ach, xd. Wir wollen es
ja mal nicht übertreiben.
Und jetzt kann man sagen Clean,
dann löscht man das Image
und
jetzt ist alles weg.
So muss das sein. Ein sehr
nicees Tool, oder?
Ich clone mir das mal kurz,
weil das SourceCode Repo können wir
heute auch für unseren Shit-Hair-Test
ausprobieren.
Repos...
Her,
und ich muss mal kurz
auf GitHub was gucken.
Yet Up!
Ah!
Ja, alles gut.
Alles gut, passt.
Wir klonen mal kurz das Repo.
Git clone
for MChamp already exists.
Ja, das ist der von gestern.
Den kann ich wegschmeißen.
Ja, ja, yes.
Alles weg.
Git clone for MChamp.
Ja,
for MChamp.
Also, ihr könnt es euch jetzt kurz
aussuchen.
Was wir zuerst machen sollen.
Wie wird es ausgesprochen? GitHub oder
Shit Hub?
Eindeutig. Genauso wie das
hier logischerweise auch Shit EA
ist.
Was ja sogar zutreffend ist.
Ist es über System Neustart
persistent? Nein, das ist Absicht.
Das sind einfach nur on the fly
Test for M's. Wenn man mal kurz
Test for M's braucht. Ich will gar nicht, dass das
persistent ist. Ne, ne. Sobald das ordnungsgemäß
runtergefahren wird, der Rechner, das ist alles
weg.
Ne, will ich nicht.
Weil, weil Gtea
hat jetzt GitHub Action Support.
Das will ich ausprobieren.
Ich weiß, dass das Gtea jetzt irgendwie
China-Chinesen Zeug ist.
Warum pipest du Yes nach M? Warum nicht mit
Y bestätigen?
Weil man ganz schön oft mit Y bestätigen
muss, wenn man so ein Gitverzeichnis löschen will.
Oder Dateien löschen will.
Und wenn ich ein Yes nach M pipe,
dann weiß ich, was ich mache.
Nämlich, dass ich zu jeder einzelnen
Datei Yes sagen will. Ansonsten müsste
ich jetzt 90 mal Yes drücken.
Wie viel Gigabyte die Sekunde kann
dein Yes...
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren.
Moment, wo haben wir hier
PV?
Ich brauch PV. Wie heißt
das Package hier? 25.
Wollen wir mal
gucken, wie viel Gigabyte die Sekunde
mein...
Muss man das jetzt...
Ich glaub, das muss man jetzt umleiten. Ach, der F0, das funktioniert jetzt nicht.
Ich pack 7,5...
7,9...
Also, sagen wir mal so.
7,7
im Durchschnitt vielleicht.
Gigabytes die Sekunde schafft
mein Yes. Exzellent,
oder? Das wollte ich schon
immer mal wissen.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen
auch durch den
so...
RAM...
Wobei, RAM packt mehr.
Aber ich glaube, das reicht.
7 Gigabyte die Sekunde, oder?
Wofür steht PV?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wofür PV steht.
Ich kann nicht sagen. Ich kann nicht sagen, was
PV macht.
PV piped, genau. Monitor progress of data
through a pipe. Warum ist PV
heißt? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich geh davon aus, dass es das Tool
auch schon blazingly fast written in
Rust gibt.
Es gibt mittlerweile alles rewritten in Rust.
Aber da kannst du Sachen
durchpipen. Und
das gibt es dann einfach wieder aus.
Damit kannst du checken,
wie viel da an Daten quasi durch die
Pipes durchschiebst.
Die haben CI
auch schon. Wirklich?
Aber ich kann das...
Forgeo,
wie auch immer, kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Und haben die aber auch CI?
Pipe viewer, aha.
Welche Version haben wir hier?
Okay.
Wo sieht man jetzt hier?
Auf dem Projekt
die Tags.
1.19.
Okay.
Die haben quasi...
Die haben quasi das...
Wieder... Die sünden das regelmäßig
mit Upstream.
Aber stellen sicher, dass kein China-Chinesen
bei Zeug drin ist, oder was?
Naja, wenn es sich anbietet
wieder. Also Leute,
ihr könnt es euch jetzt aussuchen,
was wir machen. Ich meine, wir haben ein bisschen
Zeit. Es kann sein,
dass ich MMO-Kreisel-Crime machen muss.
Eventuell. Mal schauen.
Aber ich glaube,
es sieht nicht so aus,
sind Leute da.
Was hat GTA denn gemacht?
Ich kriege das Drama nicht mehr genau
so zusammen.
Irgendeine Firma in Hongkong,
aus Hongkong, also
Kikomodets aus China,
haben das Ding
versucht zu vermarkten.
Mit irgendeiner
China-Chinesen-Firma.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, warum
sich alle aufgeregt haben. Es haben sich zumindest
im Dezember war das, glaube ich,
ein bisschen her, wo es das Drama gab.
Da haben sich irgendwie alle aufgeregt
und Codeberg hat es dann irgendwie
gefargt zu
...
Meine Güte, können die sich nicht mal
bitte schön Projektnamen ausdenken,
die irgendjemand aussprechen kann?
Es hätte bloß noch ein
.io-Domain gefehlt.
Dann hätten wir dann
...